for everyone who said that Trump can't
win Trump mocks Chris Christie's weight
Don't Call Him a fat pig
made fun of yes of the former New Jersey
governor and 2024 Republican nomination
rival in a speech in New Hampshire it's
really funny because he said Chris
Christie he's eating right now he can't
be bothered when he said that there was
like 30 people in the media that were
just like yes he's back that's when a
man in the crowd shouted out to prod
Trump sir please do not call him a fat
pig I'm trying to be nice Don't Call Him
a fat pig you can't do that
that is the masterful anti-insult insult
of trump
when he goes on stage and he says you
know you've got uh Chris Christie some
people call him a fat pig we don't do
that it's mean that's his that's his
game and it's brilliant because he's
insulting him what do you mean I said
don't call him a fat pig you know
Trump's back I saw that as soon as I saw
the story Don't Call Him a fat pig I
busted out laughing and I'm like this is
what Trump excels at he is an
Entertainer he builds confidence by
being in control of the stage and he's
got it now
not to imagine Chris Christie is very
pro-war so I don't know who's going to
vote for that guy anyway but uh I do
think this is a sign as silly and stupid
as it may be that Donald Trump has the
energy to win again I'd prefer a lot of
other people to be completely honest
only thing I'm really saying is I hope
Trump fires everybody
you know yeah I don't Trump is good at
firing people I'll give him that it's
just he's never been good at hiring them
so that's true and he wasn't his first
time around but I'm really hoping that
this time around he's just seeing red
the whole time and yeah I know I I if
it's Trump great that's fine but for me
it's like look I want a president that's
going to
significantly cut the government yeah
he's not your best bet
yeah he probably I mean compared to who
else again Vivek maybe I'm just saying
because just given like I expect him to
piss a lot of people off but I expect
him to sign tons of spending bills and I
mean just just looking at how he I mean
I know I'm a Libertarian but even if
you're a conservative judging how Trump
governed like gun control spending the
expansion of government like he was just
awful he's the only one that looks at
the uh security establishment or the
intelligence establishment or whatever
as the enemy I agree with you there so
like do you know I I think that he would
make I just think that's in the in the
FBI I think it would make sense do you
think it would make changes like a
Personnel change I don't see him like
actually taking a hatchet to it but do
you know the extent of what he did with
the Drone program I know he made it uh
secretive and gave control to the
generals his support yes yeah I mean
they stopped recording how many drone
strikes were happening under his
presidency
um so they don't actually know what the
number is it was very high though
um you know people rightly point out how
many bombs Obama dropped because it was
abysmal but uh Trump uh I think he he
didn't drop more than Obama but he
dropped uh more in his first four years
than Obama did in either four-year
period so it was I mean he dropped a lot
of bombs and then he then there's a
bunch off the Record we just don't know
how many we don't know how much where
they were dropped or anything like that
do you think that what's your view of
how we handle say like Afghanistan or
Syria just complete instant removal of
all assets and Personnel so I think I
mean it's a mess no matter how you leave
the problem with Afghanistan I think I
talked about this last time I was on
here was the order of operations you
know like Phil said that you get the
people out first and then the military
at last but also
Donald Trump had made deals with the
Taliban about like Hey we're out of here
in May and then Joe Biden came in and
was dragging his feet and was like nope
I'm gonna make my own Taliban deal and
we're gonna leave in September and then
the Taliban was like well what the heck
why are you still here so you know there
are ways we could actually start pulling
troops out but Trump was actually
stifled by a lot of his generals he
wanted people out of Afghanistan he
wanted to start withdrawing and they
screwed him up
um that was one of the best things about
his presidency was the deal with the
Taliban and trying to pull him out so
the issue with the drone strikes is
if you immediately remove all the troops
you get what Joe Biden did
granted I think Joe Biden sabotaged
Afghanistan intentionally the the the
the abandoning of Bagram Air Force Base
was a psychotic move
what I see with Trump and this is not to
defend drone strikes should never have
been engaged in these wars I think
Trump's strategy was
increase drone strikes and pull our
troops out man once our troops are out
decreased drone strikes we're gone well
Trump increased troops in Afghanistan in
the beginning of his presidency he did
try he did start trying to pull him out
eventually but at the beginning of his
presidency on war he was awful yeah he
fires 59 tomahawks into Syria yeah he
was just ramping everything John Bolton
and then toward the end he was kind of
like all right all right all right you
know maybe I actually should pull some
troops out but so I I think one of the
only ways you effectively withdraw from
Afghanistan in the way that uh would be
to you basically use drone strikes as a
placeholder as you remove personnel and
then you rescind the drone strikes you
need you need a wall to stop what
happened and I think I think Joe Biden
as awful as what he did gave us a window
into into into how not to respond in
terms of the mistakes he did use a drone
strike though after
um
what was it after I after that Isis K
bombing right he did use a drone strike
and killed like 11 civilians with it or
something right right right and my point
is this
if you are trying to actively withdraw
all your troops from say Afghanistan you
you can't just recall them all instantly
there's got to be a tapered pullback of
certain areas you obviously don't
abandon Bagram Air Force Base my point
is that I think Trump's strategy
probably not even his but probably some
advisor was
increase the drone strikes to create
pressure get our troops out decrease
drone strikes release pressure we're
gone
I think the problem with Afghanistan was
extending the leave date by like six
months so that's Joe Biden that is Joe
Biden all right and then Joe Biden says
we're going to pull our troops out
abruptly in the middle of the night
without informing any of our partners in
the region without informing the Afghan
security forces and then they're left
with no Logistics so you got guys flying
helicopters being like where am I going
for fuel who's is anyone there what's
happening just gone in an instant
Optics it was all because he didn't want
of course it was Trump's yup Afghanistan
withdrawal plan yep
I mean what an evil piece of garbage he
wasn't 19 people died because of it yeah
I mean I think more than that we're
talking about 19 Americans right yeah
yeah
how many how many how many civilians a
lot yeah bystanders are caught up in
this and now living under the Taliban so
I mean it's you know Joe Biden is plenty
fair game but also George W bush is who
everyone really should hate we didn't
need to be in Afghanistan for 20 years
we could have had Osama Bin Laden in
2000 it wasn't we we did I do not
believe the U.S went to Afghanistan for
Osama Bin Laden no they didn't they went
there for poppy for heroin and oil and
lithium lithium they didn't go there for
heroin they went there for lithium
there's actually photos of U.S soldiers
guarding poppy fields right they were
harvesting and that and and that may be
a component but I think it was probably
resources strategic access a a pincer
move on Iran access to lithium seizing
the region before China or Russia could
take it and nation building and they use
Osama Bin Laden as an excuse to launch
that Invasion and they use wmd as an
excuse to invade Iraq why
anybody know geography it rocks over
here Afghanistan's over here Iran be
right in the middle
John Bolton Said I think it was in 2018
by this time next year we'll be
celebrating in Tehran that's what that's
what their goal was I I I'm glad you
brought up George Bush because we talk a
lot about how Biden is the worst
president ever in people's lifetimes a
lot of people will say that it was
George Bush it was George Bush yeah that
guy started this the worst 9 11 war on
terror crap the Patriot Act all the war
that we've seen in the Middle East was
started by those people all the power
that the Democrats are using against
conservatives now with the Department of
Homeland Security and everything you can
thank George W bush I think to be fair
though we can say that Cheney was the
worst president because I don't think
George I almost said that
Cheney I believe maybe you can confirm
this read that George Bush had actually
given authority of the Air Force to Dick
Cheney do he is that what it was he had
on 9 11 it was Cheney's call oh yeah fly
the planes to defend the tower yeah it
was Cheney's called a not shoot down the
plane that hit the Pentagon
daddy's boy getting into Power mess of a
presidency and then they put his dad's
buddy in as the VP to let him run the
show if you don't mind me going on a
short side Trail here just because vivec
put out a Vivek Rama Swami put out a
great tweet about 9 11. UM and it was
about flight 77 it was about the uh
hijackers who flew flight 77 into the
Pentagon kalid al-midar into waffle
housemate and how they had Saudi royalty
directly wiring or indirectly wiring
them money uh prince bandar who was the
uh Saudi ambassador to the United States
wired money to Meyer all by Omi in the
United States and then he gave it to uh
Khalid almadar into waffle housemate who
later flew the plane into the Pentagon
and this is something that a lot of 9 11
conspiracy theorists completely missed
because it's flashy and sexy and
everything to deny a plane hitting the
Pentagon on or deny a plane going down
at Shanksville but if you just deny
these things instead of looking into it
you actually find out that the true
anomalies
of people doing Shady things are mostly
involved with flight 93 and flight 77
and I'm not the expert on this I just
know people who are Ryan Dawson Adam
Fitzgerald they've done extensive
research on all this stuff go check them
out but flight 77 Khalid almadar and
Waffle House me the 28 Pages the 911
report just go check that out it's very
eye-opening I thought that for 20 years
they had one story which was it was just
they were just there working together
for fun like there was no connection and
then all of a sudden the last two years
more documents came out that show the
connection to the Saudi Prince let me
let me read this from the vague so he's
uh he says Mike Pence says today that he
was deeply offended that I don't trust
that the government told us the truth in
the in the 911 Commission report
he says well I find it offensive that
our government repeatedly lies to us
here's the truth the FBI quietly
Declassified documents in 2021 that
definitively reveal the government lied
to the public about basic facts of Saudi
Arabia's involvement in 911 until
documents were Declassified and they
changed their story 20 years later Omar
al-bayumi a 42 year old graduate student
welcomed housed set up bank accounts and
gave rent money to the first to Al-Qaeda
hijackers after they landed in Los
Angeles in January of 2000 albayumi
claimed to have met the two terrorists
entirely by Chance the 911 Commission
report verified that Naomi's altruism
was in the name of hospitality as he
claimed the FBI 20 years later changed
its story and documents Declassified
last year the bureau affirmed that biomi
was in fact an agent of the Saudi
intelligence service who worked with
Saudi religious officials and reported
that the Kingdom's powerful Ambassador
in Washington U.S government officials
continue to lie about other matters of
public importance the origin of corrid
I'm sorry the origin of covid knowledge
about uaps Hunter Biden's laptop and how
our money is actually being spent in
Ukraine the Nashville Shooters Manifesto
with a complicit media that just accepts
the prevailing narrative without
question this fuels rampant public
distrust there is no credible evidence
that 911 was an inside job but
ironically when the government
systematically lies about Saudi
involvement and the media runs
interference that lends plausibility to
and otherwise unlikely claim there's no
such thing as a noble lie with all due
respect to the former VP the reason that
people don't trust the government is
because the government doesn't trust the
people man Mike very well said wow he's
great I want to vote for this guy yeah
do it yeah I do hope he wins me too I
think to be honest I don't think he's
gonna win he need to be selected somehow
like Obama was well his deep State needs
to get involved I'm I'm surprised he's
not pulling higher already considering
he's he's broken into second place a
couple times and in the prediction
markets he has I'm surprised he's just
every time I see him do an event he's
hitting a home raise and he's hitting a
grand slam well he basically he echoed
or just talked about exactly we were
just talking about that 20 years after
the 911 Commission report had lied to
the American people about the terrorists
involvement with the Saudi Prince but
they didn't bring up the Saudi Prince
maybe at the time I don't know 20 years
later they they admit we were lying when
Donald Prince was involved in funding
these guys when Donald Trump said that
Chris Christie was probably eating he
said Vivek is catching up onto sandus
and he's good yeah that was like
knows how to play the game all respect
between Trump and Vivek I like it yeah
defense like that in 2016 though it was
uh Trump and Cruz until right up till
the end they were like buddy buddy you
know like he wouldn't tread on Trump's
shoes and then I I bet the gloves come
off of that fake has has handled his his
reason for running and his criticism
criticisms of trump masterfully he's
defended Trump on all the most important
things praised Trump on all the good
things that he's done and I think his
core uh issue is that he's mostly just a
younger more active and in an involved
individual who thinks that he could do a
better job
what's Trump going to say to that thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time